Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show.
I am Jessy Dallimore, host of the Dallimore Daily
on YouTube and the podcast. I doubt it. Let's
talk about Congress today. Let's talk about
congressional committees specifically. Let's
talk about the sacred duty and the work that
could be being done by passing legislation to
make the lives of Americans better and easier.
That is not what's taking place. The
Republicans have wanted power for so long,
they were willing to lie, steal, and
she'll lie, steal and cheat, as it were,
to get it. And now that they're there, it's chaos.
24 seven. It is circus atmosphere, 24 seven. It's
getting nothing done. 24 seven. Jim Jordan I mean,
if you need any more evidence of the statement
I just made. Jim Jordan is the judiciary
chairman in the House of Representatives.
Jim Jordan and Matt Gaetz, who's also a member of
the Judiciary Committee, offered up an amendment
today. And you can you can judge whether you think
this is going to make your life better, more rich,
easier. I'll let you be the judge. He offered
up an amendment that they start every hearing
of the Judiciary Committee in the House of
Representatives by putting their hand in their
heart and reciting the Pledge of Allegiance.
This was the important work of Congress today.
At least many minutes were taken up by this
debate. And rather than just go along with it,
Democrats rightfully pushed back on this. And
we're going to talk about that. But, you know,
let me go off on a tangent here. Look, I served
in the United States Marine Corps for many years.
I don't understand. The Pledge of Allegiance.
I don't understand this this this attempted
indoctrination of our children, of making them
recite this thing. I know you can opt out of it,
but to to swear allegiance to a piece of cloth.
It's very weird to me. It's very strange to
me. And for congresspeople to be wasting
taxpayer dollars trying to get an amendment
that they start every session with the Pledge of
Allegiance is just dereliction. It's insanity.
And luckily, David Cicilline, he was
there, a congressman from Rhode Island,
to push back on this and offer
his own amendment that if you
participated in an insurrection or you were an
insurrection apologist, you don't get to say.
The Pledge of Allegiance. Watch this.
Speaker 2: Thank you, Mr. Chairman. You know,
Mr. ICE, you just made reference to
how important it is for us to display
our commitment to the Constitution and
to commit to defend it aggressively.
So I'd like to offer an amendment to the
amendment, adding in the second paragraph where
the chair may designate an individual to lead the
Pledge of Allegiance ad the following language
provided. However, the pledge shall not be led
by an individual who supported an insurrection
against the government of the United States in any
way. Because I think if we adopt this amendment,
then we will be truthful in in representing that.
Stating this pledge is an affirmation of your
defense of democracy and the Constitution.
It's hard to take that claim seriously if,
in fact, an individual who in any way supported
an insurrection against the government is allowed
to leave the pledge. So I would ask Mr. Gates
to accept this friendly amendment, and I look
forward to supporting the gentleman yield for
the first associate civil support the amendment.
To make sure that someone who led an insurrection
against United States doesn't make a mockery of
the Pledge of Allegiance and stand before this
committee with their hand over their heart
claiming to support the Constitution mercilessly.
I. My concern would be if your definition of an
insurrection is objecting to electors, then there
would be many Democrats on the committee that
wouldn't be eligible to lead the pledge since so
many. That's not my definition. I mean, the last
Republican president, Lincoln sworn in absentee.
Speaker 1: Voters was George Herbert
Walker Delaney.
Speaker 2: My time
escapes. I will allow the chairman
to determine whether or not someone
has participated in insurrection. And I say
it's I think this language is important with
the gentleman. Further yield. I'm asking, Mr.
Gates, will you now accept the amendment? Well,
I'm I'm concerned that that you may be
disqualifying to many of your own members,
Mr. Cicilline. I'm not concerned about
that at all. Then agree to the amendment
with this. Let's make this real. If you
want to give someone the right to stand
before the House Judiciary Committee and lead
the Pledge of Allegiance at a bare minimum,
let's guarantee that that person has not
participated or supported or in any way helped
and overthrow of the government of the United
States with the gentleman. A simple proposition.
Speaker 1: Now, this is a giant waste of time.
I've previously stated that I still think that,
but making the point is good. Making the point
that David Cicilline is making here is is a noble
cause, because we need to point out hypocrisy
where we see it, and especially in Congress,
we do. And that's a full time job. When
you have Republicans in leadership.
To support those who who attempted to overthrow
the United States government by way of force.
By trying to delay the certification.
Bye bye. By violating the Constitution,
by delaying a constitutionally mandated
certification of electoral voters. It flies
in the face of disrespect for the Constitution.
You see a lot of these goofballs who carry
around in their pocket a little a little pamphlet.
That's the Constitution, and they wave it around.
And they act like they're they're they're
noble patriots. Don't tread on me, they say.
Yet they full throated lee some with fists in
the air in solidarity like Josh Hawley supported.
The insurrection against the United States. They
knew what was taking place and they supported it.
So it's it's hypocrisy run amok for Matt
Gaetz, of all people, to ask that they
recite the Pledge of Allegiance in honor of
our country as some masturbatory patriotism,
because that's what this is. They've watched
their dear leader literally hug and kiss the
flag. And they believe that's the path
to enlightenment. It's all just gross.
But what would you expect when you got
Matt Gaetz and Jim Jordan in the mix?